hello everyone and welcome to polka
texts for those that don't already know
parka text in shorts is basically a very
small indie game and it's a bit of a
tribute to roller coaster tycoon one
really it's created by only three people
one of which only works on the music so
that's a really small team and so far I
actually really like it I've been
following the development of the game
for many months now and finally decided
to buy it just about three days ago I
think and since I bought it I don't
think I've been playing any other video
games have actually been sort of
addicted to the game and after a couple
days of practicing decided to actually
try a bit of a let's play over here now
this let's play is gonna be very similar
pretty much the same really to my roller
coaster tycoon 3 let's play I'm just
going to be time-lapse in these videos
not doing in-game stuff I already feel
like enough people are doing in-game
stuff in this game already as it is and
I really want to try this that being
said this will be a bit of an
experimental park where I just see if
this style of making videos is really
gonna work in this game and whether I
haven't gonna be able to actually work
in this game and actually create some
nice stuff which is completely fail in
which case we are still in the pre-alpha
of this game so if it's too bad I
suppose I might just try and build a new
park for the beta and for the full
release and stuff like that you have to
keep in mind that so far in the game is
also quite unfinished and it is in an
isometric viewpoint like rollercoaster
cone one and two and not completely free
3d like rollercoaster can three years
even though it's in 3d it does have an
isometric camera that is if you don't
use any models to get different cameras
but I'll go back to that later on so
there's a lot less detail at the moment
so I'm arguably gonna be able to finish
parks way earlier than I usually do in
rollercoaster k3 it's gonna take way
less time so I think I'll just build a
number of parks throughout this let's
play but really that all just depends on
how ever it's gonna work out in the near
future I suppose for this park I am
going to try to actually make a a Alpine
sort of Park which is going to be a bit
tough because there are a couple of
things that I should probably tell about
this
without molds we don't really have too
much custom scenery without mods we
don't have too much scenery yet and
really all the balls and building
elements that you see right here is
actually modeled into the game so far
there are two walls since we've got a
generic and western wall sets and there
is one with flags and banners which I
got but other than that there aren't any
scenery molds yet and I haven't really
picked any up yet so I don't even have
too many building elements so far so
it's gonna be a bit tough to actually
figure out what I kind of want to do to
get this park to look at least somewhat
Mountain ish though I do have to add one
thing which I already really like about
this game is the fact that you can see
all those different posts and those
actually all just part of simple war
pieces but since this game actually
doesn't really use any advanced excuse
it's rather a text jeweller's it's not
completely text alerts but they're very
washed out and especially with these
wall sets they don't have any techies
whatsoever you can really just clip
certain faces into each other and you
won't have any trouble with it so yeah
and already even though there are just
two building sets there is already well
the possibilities to get a lot of detail
and you to your Park and I really like
it so far so this end this entrance is
just gonna be a simple standard sort of
entrance pretty much the templates
entrance which you've probably seen a
thousand times by now just a couple of
ticket booths at least they're supposed
to be sort of ticket booths it's not
gonna really work yet there aren't
specific pieces like that but it gets
the idea across I suppose especially
from the simple isometric view like this
and behind this I am planning to have a
small simple Main Street I'm not gonna
make it too similar to the Disney Main
streets it's this Park I planned should
be more of a park that's built
throughout the years rather than planned
ahead like Disney parks are so I'll get
a simple Main Street in and make it look
a little bit similar symmetrical but
it's not gonna be completely like a
Disney park so they wouldn't be
buildings all around it and I already
got some attractions and pretty soon
into the park and that's pretty much my
planning so far one thing which I do
have to add though there is not a lot of
choice yet
foliage there are a couple of simple
pine trees and there are some poplars
and just regular sort of trees but it's
other than that's it's a pretty limited
choice so that's something that I still
kind of have to mess with one thing
which you can see over here which is
really amazing and works out really well
in this game already is the fact that
you actually have a Collard wheel rather
than with rollercoaster controlled so
far and voila Kousaka tree and actually
all the Yuval the coaster tycoon game so
far you actually have a color wheel from
which you can choose your college so
it's practically limitless colors the
one thing which should still be worked
on is the fact that you can actually
have a pallets because right now I am
actually saving my colors into a notepad
because you can't save any colors within
the game so just to be able to actually
get the same colors I have to leave the
game every once in a while and actually
get my notepad file with the exact
colors that I want which is why
sometimes the video pauses for little
bits so that's a bit of an explanation
for that there's also some things where
you can obviously notice that it's a
very unfinished game at the moment now
in just two different paths and there
isn't really a variety it's not a
problem yet in this main street since
you don't usually use too many paths
sort of textures in just one Main Street
but in the rest of the park I'm pretty
much forced to still use the same as for
though that might also be updates while
I built this park we are currently in
the pre-alpha built for B and the
updates are somewhat regularly so while
I'm still building this bike I might
actually be some new stuff appearing and
actually working on the walls inside the
game as well since the vols sets or at
the moment just mods but right now as we
speak the developers are actually
working on wall sets as well but um yeah
that's none of my concern yet I
basically just want to finish this main
street and make it look at least a
little bit Alpine I do have two and it's
really tough to actually make it work
and I'm not really sure about how well
it actually works right now but the
general atmosphere is generally where
I'm going for I'm not going to be able
to really put too much detail into these
buildings it's really just gonna be I'm
just gonna touch the general surface of
what am i want my park to look like
and yeah that's pretty much why I won't
be working as long on certain things
though I do have to add also that's what
I feel the charm is to this game because
right now I can't even explain the fact
that I've been playing this cave for
three days in a row and I'm still not
getting tired of it and that's really
what I feel is good about this game but
it also makes it a bit of a like it or a
hated it's sort of scenario it's similar
to roller coaster tycoon one in a sense
that I feel you can build a part you can
build a bike in general and it'll look
like something from isometric view but
as soon as you actually try the mods to
get it in 3d view and actually get a
peep view or a flying camera it just
kind of destroys the magic and what I
think the magic is in this game and
what's kind of got me hooked so far is
the fact that it's so extremely
unrealistic because in real life of
course it's way to cartoon it actually
be like real life but it kind of
resembles reality enough to kind of
fantasize about your Park and how it
would look in real life enough to
actually be satisfied with the cartoony
look and that's what I feel is kind of
what makes me so satisfied building
stuff in this game and probably the fact
that it's much easier so far than Ambala
coaster tycoon 3 for instance or even
rollercoaster tycoon 2 since you don't
have to worry about all those small
details or even the annoying hitbox is
that those games have because the
hitboxes are actually a collision
detection in general is actually
something that you don't have with all
these objects which I really like so far
and another thing is that I just
personally I like the art style as much
as its mobile phone ish and maybe even a
bit similar to roller coaster tycoon for
mobile so far I really like the graphics
especially when you kind of see the
peeps pretty cute and it's just it's a
bit of a yeah love it or hate it it's
sort of cartoony look I think but I love
it so far and here's what I actually
tried to have some Austrians sort of
alpine buildings but this is where I am
just going to fail on every single
instance where I'll be trying to
actually build Alpine buildings because
some of the fundamental pieces of course
that you want for an Alpine themas
simply not there
since there is a Wild West sets you can
actually have those Western four sons
and things like that but you can't have
overhanging roofs that alpine buildings
always have or the little alpine
building clock towers so there's still a
lot missing to actually make that theme
work but it's something that I'm willing
to sort of mess with I didn't want to
just make a western themed Park it's
kind of not willing to do that since it
was already a theme that you got within
a building sets and I didn't want to
exactly copy that but yeah the main
thing which I'll be focusing on in this
hike is just general Park planning which
is this game is probably going to be
better for them rollerCoaster Tycoon 3
in a way also similar to rollercoaster
tycoon 2 much more focused on the
general look of things rather than the
very individual buildings and very
individual well everything really has so
that's also something that I'll be
focusing on I might actually finish this
park within about 20 episodes that might
actually still be a very that might
actually still be too many might
actually be very shortly but yeah that's
the the general planning and if there's
anyone who also plays Park attacked by
the wayne has any tips on what I'm
building be some far from perfect and I
only have this game for a couple of days
and don't worry to shout at my stuff
sucks and tell me what actually do
instead because I would still like to
improve on this one of the main issues
that I mean one of the main issues but
one of the main things which I still
want to do in this game is improve which
I think I'm doing with pretty much
everything I build so yeah I always like
getting feedback whether it's positive
or negative it's always something I can
do something with and I also do have to
add I think yeah it's next episode that
I'll be working on a rollercoaster so
you'll be able to see the coaster
creative as well for those that don't
already know
Orkut X does have a piece by piece
coaster created like rollercoaster
tycoon
one two and three have but it's a bit
different in a way that you don't choose
the exact pieces that are pretty laid
out for you but you've got a lot more
choice in the different banking's that
you have you can you have full 180
degree control over the banking and it
goes in steps of five degrees though
that's a really versatile and there are
actually
you can go from a slope to a straight
piece and curve and go to a different
Bank as well it's it's really hard to
explain it but you'll see it later on
it's very versatile much better I think
than the editor of rollercoaster tycoon
3 at least that's been my experience so
far but yeah I'm almost running out of
time the last couple of things that I
wanted to do over here is just simple
detail placement which actually quite
handy many of these very small path
elements like park maps and signs
actually off grid and they don't have
collision detection - you're very free
and where you want to place them and
that makes it so much more versatile
really like that so far but yeah this is
it for this episode so thank you guys
for watching and I'll see you guys in
the next episode in which I'll actually
be building a junior coach - so see you
later guys